today's episode is brought to you by
America's best unlimited network don't
miss a show with unlimited data from
t-mobile
hello everybody welcome bonus trailer
commentaries and we got a big one for
you it's guardians of the galaxy vol 2
all tuned and we're getting a little
flak on this on the comments there Dan
spent ironing as well we knew that when
I'm do this one knowing we might get a
little heat on this and let's get right
to it because we will watch the trailer
for those of you who don't normally
watch a show we watch full trailer talk
about it operate them deleted jokes we
have yes we have some deleted scenes
that we do from the booth before we get
to the trailer let's just do some broad
thoughts dan what do you think um look
we went in knowing a nice Pacific as I
came in a little late commodification
and chimed in at the end yeah look I
like this movie this is a good movie to
combine the movie but it's not a perfect
movie no I'm not ever not every movie is
right nowwhat Guardians ecology wanting
to was a fun movie I laughed watching it
I had a good time watching it there were
some things that weren't as good as in
the first movie I thought like it was
it's a good movie it's fun but it's like
people sue think the nas trailer should
be one of two things either we love
every movie or we crap on every movie
and we're not here to do either one of
those like you know if you watch the
show you kind of watch to get our
perspective on it and our equals our
professors our common perspective on it
was that guards the galaxy was fun it
was a good time
we enjoyed watching it but it was maybe
I wasn't a first really well-intentioned
to give all these characters depth and
arcs but it just felt like it was on
fast forward as far as the character
development that they were trying to do
in the in the movie it was a lot of kind
of like retro actively telling you the
problems that these characters were
going through instead of showing them to
you it was like oh remember yondu that
kind of like side semi antagonist from
the first one well actually he's had
this whole thing with the Ravagers and
there's this rule about trafficking
children and he's got he's actually a
good guy because he was doing it to
protect ego like they were trying to do
a lot of characters because there's it's
a big ensemble pieces like seven of them
and they're just trying to do it all
month fast forward it can remind me
Voltron that way yeah well yeah I would
argue it's better than old
it doesn't alter our me we say it it's
better we visit ever better than ever in
the Marvel part to accept Winter Soldier
like there's an Ultron spent or tuned to
a nine-man - it's better than oh you
know a good would you know chunk of the
Marvel movies but I was with Spencer
like I like my big thing with the movie
was like particularly rocket and yondu
were two characters that like barely
interacted at all the first one it just
seemed like they had this kind of forced
thing where it's like rocket was kind of
more of an a-hole and this one that he
wasn't the first one and the first one
had kind of softened his character like
he got part of a family now like they
had all kind of got into this family
thing and then now all of this conflict
arises again and like rocket has to be
that character so that he and yondu can
have this big scene of like we're the
same you and me we could suit so you
have to be really affected by what's
happening with each other because we're
the same person and it just felt like
there's a lot of telling and and yeah I
mean I was a Spencer just felt like a
lot of like we have to get these we have
to tell you what these characters are
feeling because we didn't they don't
have their own label Adler said yeah
exactly and again and I was evaluating
further like Timmy it's like that's what
I loved about the first time there was
just a lot of fun original things like
that the Prison Break scene for example
was like a really fun sequence that was
sort of fun so it was surprising and
unexpected and exciting there well I
didn't have any of those moments in this
one as much like it's even I totally
agree with you on what you're saying
about yondu and rocket etc but even on
the rewatch the first time I watched the
movie the first time I was like those
fun I left happy a good flop good job
everybody that's a hard thing to pull
off they did a good adventure but down a
second watch like even the whole
beginning that first act is sort of it
says point got to get to a got to get to
B got to get to see like it starts off
and it's really sort of rushed weird way
of like okay we're fighting a big alien
got the batteries there's the gold
people so gold people up to Q his dad oh
he has daddy issues up his dad saves
them oh here's his dad it's like it just
very felt very by-the-numbers in the
plot where i couldn't like there was
nothing fun or different from the action
from the plotting it just felt very much
like okay I have to just go in this very
specific lying low to get us is like
point I feel like most movies are
structured in a very similar way like
superhero movies like that but they did
they didn't hide it well enough yeah
cool because we created I think
guardians did a much better job at it
because you
learning these things through the
characters you're learning about them as
they go now we know the characters so he
just I felt like we were resorting to a
lot of the same tricks and I think there
are good sequel Winter Soldier is the
perfect simple if it did do different
things did figure out a way to up it and
I think if they had not forced all those
all the coupling to happen I feel like
Drax and mantis and Gamora everyone had
a you know coupling it's like if they
figure out a way and like it we said
would they they also had to hate be
jerks again to hate each other just to
get a point like I think they could have
found a stronger internal struggle that
actually divided them to make them come
back together and I don't like any of it
was earned way they did that thing and
we actually when we were writing this
site I brought it up and it just was
this - it was a weird obscure point that
never over the trailer but like this
movie reminds me a lot of Star Trek
beyond start hurt me onto the same thing
they're all the shift together they're a
crew and gone through with them to
movies with guardians their whole movies
about them come together as a crew and
then immediately there's this big attack
by these big aliens and the ship crashes
and they split up and it's like at the
whole point the last movie was they're
learning to be a crew together just like
with Star Trek the whole point of those
movies is they're learning to be a crew
together and then immediately in the
movie you crash and then they split up
well that whole dynamic of them together
as a crew is lost because now you're
dividing them again it's like but we but
that was the last movies with dreaming
together and then you divide them
against insight or divided again they
have to learn to come back together
again but it's like but they did that in
the first movie and it's again this is
not something that ruins the movie but
it's the reason why we a lot of people
are angry because we call it forgettable
a fun but forgettable it's like but
that's kind of one of the reasons why I
think we all came at it was it's not
that it's bad it's just that there were
some things in here that struck us as
fans of guardians in a Marvel that
struck us is like I just it felt like a
step backward and and you're kind of a
familiar event conflate it was a deeper
it was a deeper attempt at doing
guardians 1 again right and whereas
guardians 1 was just a complete surprise
and of it's too bad that they can't you
know be a first impression again but our
first impression was like a movie where
you there was unexpected heart of these
people overcoming each of their like
personal demons and those in the second
one all the personal demons are still
there so somatically it didn't they
didn't change it up at all
yeah well I think we're it did have a
little bit of Marvel problems like too
many characters probably I think is
where I would argue maybe that's where
the downfall was because I think what I
would have preferred a movie that just
built their relationship stronger and
had them work together again together
and instead like you said they're sort
of alright where work so we're going to
save the galaxy but we hate each other
you're a jerk you're a dick you're a
douche like that's literally the first
action movie and then okay we're
splitting up Seija and then they come
together at the end and save each other
but there's it's not a movie like this
the Guardians is why I loved and I like
these characters and even in instead of
the teammate I want to see the team
together and I want to see them earn the
right together and they don't really I
don't feel like it was ever earned or
deserved of like them like actually
saving each other and coming to know
that they love each other just felt like
that that yondu raccoon rocky raccoon
scene was just so forced to sort of when
they're separated and they have to have
a reason like you I'm you it's just like
it literally says I'm leaving I didn't
figure of me and but then they are being
a little unfair because it's like it's
so it's so hard I can't even imagine
juggling all the things you have to
juggle in a Marvel movie to keep the
balls in the air and a lot of people did
enjoy it so no and we're not saying
people are wrong for enjoying it but
like there's so many things it's like
why you guys being so critical is like
that that's literally what we do our job
here with honest trailers is to take a
movie and analyze it and say did it work
just as objectively as possible taking
off the fan hat and just looking at it
as a movie like if you want a video that
tells you that every movie is great
that's fine and there's a bunch out
there and then we're not saying people
are wrong that loved this movie of
course if you love this movie you're not
wrong but like honest trailers our job
is to collectively get together
sometimes we disagree we happen to agree
on listen to collectively get together
and say taking the blinders off and
looking at the movie objectively how did
we you know with obviously a little
humor thrown in when we think of this
movie what is the what is the real truth
line I also think maybe unfairly
because it's not the movies fault it was
a this movie came out in like a second
Renaissance of superhero films where
this year we got Logan Wonder Woman and
homecoming which I just all liked more
and that's not any fault of this movie
it's just it
came out in the context of three films
and here before a lot of those well
before after Logan when we were reading
the last trailer was a you know this one
happened we don't watch all of those and
like seeing even more potential
nashandra
and this just seemed like another like
fun popcorn movie yeah so right I know
and hey you're a lot of like a big fun
popcorn movie yeah that's a relative it
is I don't I don't see how it's better
than the first one which is not the
arguments to say yeah I can see why I
guess in that youth if you love these
characters enough you're on a fun
adventure and it the stakes do feel
higher in a way and the yondu thing and
all that stuff just makes it feel like
it's a greater stake movie but I don't
know if I would argue it's it's rushed
to that it's not as alright well no the
Peter yondu thing is not the movies not
about Peter neon do the movies about
Peter and II go for a while and then ego
turns into a big space monster and like
I completely lost the track on that
story at that point because all of that
development just goes away for a big
fight and then Peter yondu again like
that's a big emotional punch at the end
of the movie for sure but that whole
relationship wasn't necessarily really
established that much in the first night
and then they kind of retro actively try
to tell you why it so how does it
aluminum finish them together yeah and
it's like it just didn't we're not
saying it's bad is just saying like this
is why we're gonna spectat maybe it
wasn't always that way together we're
dead inside yeah yeah so yeah that is it
we are dead inside and we're killing
cinema yeah alright let's watch the
trailer shall we yes let's
[Music]
from Marvel and James guy the director
and studio surprised everyone with
guardians of the galaxy comes a cool
looking super fun laugh out loud but
ultimately kind of forgettable sequels
but what it's still better than all the
other Marvel start commenting at that
point ever which I can't keep wise it's
weird order to the galaxy vol 2 Marin if
you pause like there was a point and we
cuz I remember when desmos was yesterday
I remember yes exactly
um there was a point we really there
were I there were points that were
harsher when we in the first round and
deleted yeah yeah and I think we did we
did want to make a point of like alright
because I think there's it's easy to be
honest but then it's also easy to like
adds when we supplied screws like it is
a fine line you got a wall off that edge
really obviously go that snarky harsh
line just because you didn't like a
movie like how do we make sure we're
being because you can write like just
because you can say it snarky remark is
like but does that movie deserve it and
I think there were a few that were in
there that we were like you can we could
say this here but do we really need to
and is it really even honest and I think
I said it in whole it's fun
they're cool-looking fun and laugh out
loud funny and then forgettable like
that's three positive things to one bad
well guess which I'll get invited on to
do I do think though in time time
progresses this one will be more
forgettable can we say that part of this
reason was we just did we were doing our
backlog a lot of trailer commentaries
and we got to age of Ultron and we
realized that we hedged in our minds
blinded there's too much in the trailer
itself apologizing for us thinking that
it was just kind of okay and it turns
more necessary has kind of born it's out
that like and we were one of the
pioneers to sort of push Ultron the
other way like it's good but not great
and we all collectively agree watching
it back like what it is are so hedged
our bets yeah we we should have just
said what we thought and so we did that
with this one annex feel like we're
saying we're bearing a little bit of a
bunch of an hour on the internet buying
it we'll see how history and time judges
in blast off again with Marvel space
Avengers a team of misfits who learned
how to work together in their first
movie then turn back into a hole so they
can learn it all over again
like a professional ask Oh in this
playful action comedy where the hey
monster thank you for tinnitus and we do
is simply find the danger never really
feels that imminent when you and when
directions mountains ecology little I
was thinking politics know this Jackson
vulnerable not even that but just yeah
all the hit to hit the King takes and
then even gamora's holding on to the
rope like how she's like Hulk likes that
song blown up a couple times I mean I
guess it's like they're aliens so
they're just stronger then I sit there
like a gigantic hiya you just stop
thinking that they're ever in danger
when you see them repeatedly not get
hurt I know they're aliens or the
gravity's different or he's part God but
just looking at it your your pulse stops
rising because you know that they'll be
fine haha he's just getting hit by all
the trees I didn't want to put a clock
on and I forget we didn't--we guys know
the surgery didn't fall so I'm going to
put a clock on Gamora
vs. yondu as far as space exposure
because I feel like space exposure
exposure Tyler yeah much quicker on
yondu than a war and that seems maps of
course but he tries to do it he tries
said he can't yeah for some reason yeah
I mean I get why but again that does
again that is an example somewhere we
could have gone like Berlin this week
and stays for 47 seconds versus guarding
the galaxy but because yondu clearly
dies after 12 seconds but that's the
kind of thing I think that we were just
like do we really want to go down that
road probably can't nitpick yeah keep it
general yeah
honest beyond as funny as the characters
think they are
this is at a table of nine the funny
movie let up it but us okay guys so the
funny thing is I was like we've done
this before an offense reminds me in
Caracas
I think it's what do you know get it
back a little film about our massage
eliminate Sam let me decide when to
laugh all right just shut up which is
the one that really bothers bothers me
the most was taser face because that was
a funny joke but the character of rocket
laughing that hard at it actually took
me out of it a little bit because I'm
like it's funny but like it's let me
decide how many said is this like the
movie was like telling me how funny that
joke was and it's like it's a funny joke
but it still like we kind of like we
thought like kept selling it's like
tracks laughing is it started - Drax
laughing run Mejia laugh so much it's
like in a little bit some places that's
funny when he's laughing at Peter right
that's the character in a way that's the
character I'll just write a note a tazer
is it's a it's an American brand name
it's just a funny sounding name I give a
pat take your face is just kind of funny
sounding I don't know maybe Peter quill
brought one back it's like there's
behead like there's behead name whatever
a lot electronics you think you'd figure
out taser anything maybe that's a
universal word like failure thanks now
okay fair enough I don't know a job with
all your favorite heroes like star-lord
who discovers he's the son of a god and
a [ __ ] well I don't know what you're
talking about but I like the way you say
it
Gamora who teaches the strong silent
that as trove to become a strong silent
badass with the more interesting sister
and agna baby gorilla city rocket whose
eyes don't work apparently
damn it using my left eye Perry's a too
high she's right now I say that right
super Frankie just look down you're like
a weird thing newcomer Metis with the
power of getting roasted by everyone
yeah we need this and everyone knows our
well never thought you'd be able to
always show is drunken skin tomorrow sir
to do we took a whole yes I was there
alignment and if we including herself on
one side people call it down for that
group
I'm not interested right retractor who's
become and aggressively dub sex right
did you make a penis I like a woman with
some meat on her bones my father would
tell the story of impregnating my mother
have sensitive nipples who would paint
and their regions oh look you have a
good thing going with Drax don't take it
too far in our career best carry I'd
like tripod his thing is that he doesn't
get metaphor not the needs like a
completely unfiltered like sex animal
yeah that was the yeah I know Andy you
asked us about the whole Oracle thing
yeah like that was a weird things you
like a circle pervert like not - I
remember the exact season five yeah Lara
and Victor I know it was the idea of
taking a character because like a track
to the first movie was my favorite
character and just like being the best I
like to put her in this one I would
catch it I like the boy better in the
first one it wasn't that he was bad in
this one it's just that if you look at
tracks in the first movie if you look at
Jackson this movie his character is so
heightened from one to the next I think
what you're saying is like not so much
in this movie but like don't take Drax
so broad that he's like a caricature of
what he was in the first one because
there are serious tones although he did
get that one which I love where mantis
put hold his arm while he's thinking
about his dead family that was great it
has a great moment yeah we then get a
sense he's no longer really hung up on
his bed family apart from that one teen
wasn't open Monday so I thought it was a
really great scene because you're like
oh because he's not really crying about
it he's it's always in him so I did
think that helped a ton but he was like
the stealth assassin in the first movie
like like he would just never be a
regular scene II know we call we'd say
something so funny
Hull's ronan and thinks is going to beat
him with his knife and he's kind of a
dummy in the fafsa 13d as a serious ring
um yeah he was he would diffuse scenes
with humor wouldn't expect it and here
he's like the cause and he's the Alpha
in the Omega you throw that up and the
punch line of the joke sanity I think
it's just like like tracks is great but
like over Drax can build over Drax don't
open all the tracks until Tovar directs
under balls prepare for an episode of my
two dads insanely you know that's so
high on friends being your real family
you'll swear you're watching a fast and
furious movie I finally found my family
it's all you already I not your right
family I don't have friends
boom silicon shudder space dead one is
ego the Living Planet of exposition I
call it the expansion it is my purpose
buzz yeah this was an add-on later
because I rewatched them he just all he
does just there to explain really all me
is there to tell Peter everything of all
I went to did this and then I went and I
had a whole like egg chamber all set up
yeah revealed or dioramas stages of his
like he's been waiting for eternity just
don't play no he blows them up to get to
the point and comes in tells them what
it is and then takes him the planet to
tell him what it is and then at the end
has to tell him again what it really is
it's like that literally his whole
purpose is explain things yeah which was
I think a weird up missed opportunity of
like that could have been a more
interesting konnichi ER trick of like
him actually because he sort of tells
the true story but then it's not the
truth it is why didn't he just tell a
whole fib to get startled on board and
then reveal oh it's way more evil than
that it's a credit to Kurt Russell to me
that he made it like he made it he made
it work because he is Kurt Russell and
yes we say everything's better with Kurt
Russell I mean like he made that
character work because of his delivery
and his I agree but I the more and more
I think about a wat in the end after the
rewatch is I didn't it I just feel like
it wasn't it could have been stronger
had because he sort of he's not really
lying to him at any point he sort of is
hiding certain points of the area I'm
telling the entire church yeah and it's
like but then at the end he is like well
fine I'll do without you like what was
his endgame did he want to actually work
with star-lord yeah I want to tell it to
voluntarily and because I didn't buy the
I wish there had been a little bit more
of a father in him that was disappointed
in his son is what I feel like would
have been an interesting even interlude
any higher that there was missing that's
where I lost his like when that turn
happened he doesn't become
dad big bad blue space guy and I was
like what a missed opportunity late oh
so now he's missing his dad and you're
missing your son and like it's even a
better conflict that should have been
even more heightened and actually
stronger and it's in a way well in 20
minutes at least you know but anyway you
wonder if like they made this one more
about the conflict between yondu and ego
and at the end he loses his father and
you end this movie on a kind of
reconciliatory note of yondu is now one
of the Guardians and you establish this
thing of like you even say at the end of
the movie you have yondu say he you know
he may have been he may have been your
father he wasn't your daddy and you
leave yondu alive and then in three you
do that gut punch of I agree I wonder if
that might have for us and we're not
again this is our opinion but what if
that might have been more effective I
think you could have also had Yan do
more in that battle like I think if you
had just made it because I because
another fairy Westland no but my pet
peeve is like eat was so obviously you
go was bad like it's just like all the
characters can't figure it out until the
end but it's like you're Yul Herman
mantis is like I have a secret I can
tell you sort of can tell from the
beginning like okay clearly this is
going to go right and which is fine but
then I wish they would have made him
sneakier and actually a villain or or
have the conflict if I want a son and
then telling him a whole bar at Bali
yarn and then suddenly yondu's like
watch Tom about how you actually killed
his mom and gave her the cancer like
what then so that's like there could
have been layers on layers that made it
more interesting for people and for us
not only by his dad assembly right then
be actually deceived in like his dad's
all a just I wish it could have been a
little more effective was that was the
other thing that kind of took me out of
it and it was a point I wish we could
have fitted but again it was a really
odd point that even in watching in the
theaters was the fact that and I think
that these were probably worked on in a
vacuum but the fact that civil war and
guardians to the entire dramatic
linchpin of the story both focused on
the almost the exact same moment there's
the moment in civil war when when cap is
trying to talk Tony down he says I don't
care he killed my mom and he just like
goes into Ironman mode and starts that
big huge fight and then this one
literally has the same moment as
Christmas he killed my nerd they killed
my mom and that's what gets him to start
the big fight with ego which I like that
moment
that's a great moment again like as I
step back from it I'm like that is kind
of like you it's almost the exact same
thing motivation behind both of these
movies big dramatic turning points for
managed to scale it back from what you
thought was going to be the giant battle
at the end really good small character
thing and then this one just went and it
you know you know billion lasers is a
bomb no dams there asking another friend
for tape for scotch tape for like 20
minutes unnie but then again you just
like well no one's going to get hurt
okay it's just running around asking
office supplies yeah I don't know I need
to know it's really nitpicky it's like I
mean that's kind of like it's just like
as a fan like I learn unlocking lying
around together like that's what I'm
paying to see but yeah the the finale
and the core and then the what's the
gold people's name the average showing
up to the ages that was a double beat
with them as I say sovereign I wasn't a
fan of either just felt like oh they do
stole a batteries we must get out and
now they're going to create a more lock
and be an important part I'm like well
yeah but anyway again like as a fan of
this series like even two movies more
movies in a row kind of on that same
exact emotional note I was like okay so
literally now all the Guardians the
trilled it's going to be because rocket
stole batteries from a Gold douchebag
alien is now yes them exactly been to
earth because yeah I guess Santos is no
well not a spoiler yeah the footage at
comes for for bringing birth right okay
maybe for MIDI brings birth who knows I
don't know what it is shores as he
proves everything's better with Kurt
Russell making ego the Living Planet
grounded and relatable until he goes for
Marvel villain and becomes a blue alien
made of sky beings who wants to rule the
universe lost face day only five then
everything is better with Michael robot
as John arrests were down yeah yeah he
destroyed some things that they're used
to Dairy Queen
I think anything ages if she'll have an
episode with them cleaning up a big
solid blob
maybe they sounded very loud well if
they even let them touch their loud
touch the Guardian pub I mean but I
would be fascination yeah Berbers well
space dad to proves that everything is
better with michael rooker as john do as
retcon into a good guy who just wanted
to be a good Pappy all to create maximum
emotionally I would not killed off in
the most tragic Marvel deaths it like to
take care of
I didn't buy know and Italy that or
ninety so he came back he came back he
came back he came back twice he came
back a common look thing but yeah there
axilla vermin and no one's ever not only
comment I guess it's yondu by default my
papa's y'all so get ready for a great
time at the theater as they bring back
everything you loved about the first
movie and freedom yourself the slow-mo
walks and being the same visuals to the
things you didn't think you'd come back
like the laughing if a dumb name bit
starring one who your name is it pays
amazing well could having so much me
with a body part towards I'm like get
everybody like what Bobby was a buddy is
and undercutting most of the serious
dramatic moments with jokes even the
emotional part lines until I tried some
people they're so hard to find the forms
as soon as you realize okay well calling
these movies for 10 years now let us go
without a channel or 10 minutes why
don't you morally remember father I've
always wanted to say excuse me gotta
take a whiz baby not story
Arthur me Han bro go Reena warrior
princess big green beetle bored she's
dragged Shepherd hi bird shipping Star
Fox do a barrel roll
whistle while you murk mantis toboggan
and on can you go any authentic Maya had
ready player one
deadrock the movies like it's called a
Zune it's whatever one is listening to
on earth nowadays
oh the Zune is from the early 2000s I
don't think Star Wars going to be having
when he finds out what happened to rock
and roll cut my life into pieces about
Robins that's funny
[Laughter]
wait does that mean the time line of
Marvel movies is during the Zune period
not the iPad well that's nice in 2014
right with a few months after many a
date
you have really oh I don't know in the
beginning right they go back to Tata now
like one of the Ravagers like picked it
up in a raid somewhere at some point
along the line I'm just try to make a
homecoming rocket I'm like because
technically now for the Guardians to
catch up to where we currently are
they're going to have to skip like three
or four years ahead would say maple
travel can screw up yeah mr. time
dilation yeah even Kevin Feige has
admitted they don't they say don't pay
attention to the year yes it does nice
day every or is it well there it is man
we got some custom flak but not always
say that's what I think time will tell
tale I don't know if I want to watch
some with James Gunn though I don't
think I'd want to watch it with juice I
love James Gunn I feel bad I think it's
to criticize it but that's it is what it
is we had Marvel [ __ ] you know like you
know we we did Civil War it's a it's
great
DC shills we do wonder soldier and say
it's great DC shelves we do guardians
and say it's okay
screw you or Marvel can raise their hand
they're saying they're Marvel show it's
not DC show
but yeah if we say it's great we're
talking Marvel's if we say it's okay
we're called now there's no can't wait
can't please everyone Anneliese
everybody just please yourself
I'm sure if we do a community else yeah
there's one thing you take away from
this video go clean those up so we have
some outtakes to watch let's do it
what come on stop the movies fault it
came out the same year slogan Wonder
Woman and Home Coming cookies I wish I
could forget Iron Man 2 I booked my
support
and a newcomer Ventus with the powers of
a chloroform so Krag story there wasn't
even darker with yeah yeah whoa
Green Weaver Sister Sister then I do
drag crash and uh Captain Jack arrow
MARY POPPINS y'all the Moche girl that's
no moon
space Avengers age of Ultron we're
almost done with that I like that that's
a Star Trek discography I like that one
I would have picked that one day I
wonder why and I can use delight to
build cool things what might take you a
few million years of practice Wow so
Starla can harness a celestial force
that he had almost no training using to
defeat ego a way more powerful and
experienced force user who win a Mary
Sue pause this is my little bone stick
because I I felt like that was the exact
of all the complaints the complaining
that was done about about the force
awakens this movie has Peter quill who's
just been introduced to this very
powerful force fighting ego who's very
experienced Alethia
militia using this force and he's able
to tap into his emotions harness it and
use it to defeat an emotionally
compromised opponent and everyone's fine
with it but for some reason when Ray
does the same thing it becomes a whole
conversation it's like yeah because
she's a woman yet number one ding ding
ding but also like number one it's a
movie number two it's like that just
goes to show you like that so that's
dust drama that's sci-fi attic life so
that's your latitude we think he'll get
the force again later just comes out
when L is now to go and think it's gone
but look it's comic anything can happen
to have some force in horses lettuce
batteries nano the giant brain that the
center is a planning a blown up Andy
I don't could be more logical make their
home plan
yes family I'll just get to me in don't
see oh yeah yep again I thought it was
Papa Roach did win a ferocious better
but that was never just really bugged me
that you did not hear that same debate
around the ending of this movie that you
did around the force awakens and I
thought it was pretty much the same set
up completely and we have one more all
pending is it this is so much fun I have
no clue what's happening whole endings
I'm writing the plan and rocks with this
little mental Erica why can't the planet
just like can break everyone a lot of
thing exactly I can't just like remove
the oxygen from the planet and then it
all just die immediately yeah
this has like masks on to avoid that
right just ladies removing the oxygen
rocket of course would have that in his
pocket open up the gravity is everything
core of the planet like melt them
yeah helps everybody you think it would
be easier yeah it was kind of like
Inception like why didn't he make bigger
guns
miksa fly around like all this because
the million things he could have done
that was been kind of a cooler as make
sure you Monday over the guy needs to be
read it everyone be really really
obsessed that's what now actually have
been like more of a one-on-one thing or
like they sever his connection to the
brain early on so it's just like a
weakened version he just has to play I
do know that we've knockin I did like
the moment where although guardians are
getting swallowed up by the earth and
then Peters got a pull it from his heart
to stop at all
yes that was a fun and emotional moment
it was a very good emotional an
effective emotional moment as it was in
supports awakens when they did the exact
same thing sorry ah well there we go
guys that was it right that's all the
outtakes you had yes any final thoughts
I feel like we really think we exhaust
your lines and I mean it's this thing
that people are going to say we hate
this movie now because
we didn't say it'll be in the way it's a
fun movie we express their reservations
but it is a good movie we're seeing I
think the other reason is it were being
particulars because I love these
characters I think James Gunn has
created amazing characters in a Korea
amazing universe that I will see 10 more
installments if he decides to make them
but I've you know as a fan of the
characters I just I don't know I guess I
think all fans they get a little
particular like I want this I want that
I want that whether it's fair or not and
I think that's just what my criticism is
coming from of just oh I wanted to see
them together as a team doing a little
more on something different and it felt
like a little bit of a reaction yeah
final thoughts guys denver final saw DJ
Gilbert them's my thoughts and I'm and
e-cigs are always happy to share our
thoughts of you guys will be here next
week for another house trailer with
another reaction to it I mean what movie
is it oh oh yeah no no that makes weeks
I know you guys don't do anything else
next mix is a different hat so you'll
see it will get done done cause that
know next week is the other thing we're
working on oh it's right out okay go a
lot in the work is a lot of work thanks
so much for watching we'll see you then
bye bye thanks again to t-mobile for
sponsoring today's episode check out
what makes them America's best unlimited
network at t-mobile comm slash coverage
you